[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the harry potter story
more specifically we're going to be
discussing the harry potter books
and some of the things they did better
than the films
i'm definitely not a book or nothing
type of fan but that doesn't change the
fact that the books
did just do something better adding to
this i also think it's worth mentioning
that the films did some things better
than the books but
i'm going to save that for another video
anyway i won't dawdle any longer
i present to you five things the harry
potter books did better than the movies
number five the story isn't condensed
there's something nice about the
bite-sized nature of the films
and the fact that you can binge watch
them all in a single day
basically however the more succinct
nature of the films
also means that a lot of information
from the books was left out
what's the best thing that a harry
potter fan can have that's right
more harry potter and what do the books
give us
more harry potter the books stretch out
the harry potter story
but in a good way including all kinds of
details and character developments
that were entirely overlooked by the
films for this reason
the originals the books tell the story
better
but i'm certainly not complaining about
the existence of the films either
number four attention to detail
piggybacking off of the last point
one of the reasons that the books are
better than the films is that they were
able to dive into
much more detail though the books are
still way more drawn out than the films
jk rowling still didn't seem to have any
issues packing every single chapter full
of extra details
that potterheads go crazy for i do
wonder just how long the films would
have been
if filmmakers tried to include
everything in this respect perhaps the
harry potter story
could have functioned well as a tv
series number three
point of view the films did a great job
giving us a neutral perspective on the
wizarding world
and it allowed us to seamlessly move
through the story switching our
attention from character to character
viewing them on the same plane however
something special which the books did
was give us unique insights into harry's
character
and harry's point of view because the
story is more or less told from harry's
perspective
book readers build what i would describe
to be a stronger bond with harry's
character
understanding his thought processes and
decision making throughout the story
in my view this unique perspective makes
the story more immersive
and in turn better extra characters
given that the films are
far more condensed than the books we
need to give them credit
a remarkable number of harry potter
characters make it into the film
adaptations
however that certainly doesn't mean that
all characters made the cut
in fact some fan favorites were omitted
from the films entirely
characters like peeves winky professor
bins and more
as far as i'm concerned the more
characters the better and this is one of
the points that truly sets the books
apart
from the films cohesive storytelling
this next point doesn't necessarily make
the books
better but just differently equal if
that makes sense
a number of the harry potter films were
directed by different people
which meant that as the story progressed
we were given a new individual's take on
the wizarding world
while it was certainly fun to see the
story develop and enter darker and
darker
territory each year one thing that i
liked about the books
was that they all seemed like they came
from one person not multiple
i liked the variation in storytelling
from the films but also enjoy the
consistent
more cohesive storytelling from the
books and that's it for this video
do you agree with my points do you
disagree what do you think the books did
better
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
you're a wizard owery
[Music]
you